Please welcome Scarlett Johansson.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
Yay.
We could just hug.
I know.
Yeah just.
(audience applauding)
(audience laughing)
(Scarlett laughing)
Make that seat perfect for you.
Hello!
Oh my God!
We've been texting.
It's been a long time.
I know, I know.
We've been friends for so long
and you've known me in so many iterations of my life.
I mean heartbreak, too wasted at a bar,
dancing around like fools and playing games.
We spent Christmas together that time.
We spent Christmas in Austin, Texas.
And I remember your friend's mom made,
every single piece of the meal was a casserole.
I have never had, there were nine casseroles.
It was unbelievable.
It was like green bean casserole, a sweet potato casserole,
the Turkey was a casserole.
It was crazy, remember that?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, 'cause I wasn't cooking.
So I was like, "I'll take anything you got."
(audience laughing)
And then, then we did, "He's Just Not That Into You."
And we played really good girlfriends,
and it just flowed and we started hanging out.
Which is why it means so much to have you here
'cause we've known each other, we weren't moms then.
So that scene, we weren't moms then,
but I have to remind you.
Do you remember that was in a scene,
we shot that, I think it was a CVS or
like a Rite Aid or something that they had closed.
Yes.
And they said,
"You guys, "feel free to like go shopping
"while you're in this Rite Aid."
And I think you and I bonded 'cause I was like,
"Oh my God, I love a Rite Aid," remember?
And you were like,
"This is my dream to spend all day in a pharmacy."
And so we just went up and down the aisles,
doing our shopping.
That was so much fun.
That scene I had worked with Mark and Abby, the writers,
on expressing my character's point of view
about getting rejected in several portals.
And back then there weren't half as many portals
as there are in now.
Yes, there's a lot of ways to be rejected now (laughs).
So I was wondering,
do you have any dating advice for me?
For you?
Yes.
What do you need dating advice for you, you're you?
'Cause I kinda just wanna hear
your take on dating advice.
(audience laughing)
I'm so happy being single.
I don't feel desperate, I've got kids.
So my cup runneth over, I have the most incredible friends,
the most amazing job-
Are you dating?
I try, but I am so obsessed with the collective conscious
of how difficult it can be.
How do you meet people?
Well, that's a big part of the problem.
I mean, I don't know.
I can't imagine what dating would be like with kids.
Well, that's not true, I had my daughter when I met Colin,
but we met at SNL and it was like
I'd known him for a very, very long time
through my first year hosting was his first year writing,
so that was eons ago.
And you also hosted, you're a five timer, right?
Six.
Me too six.
(audience applauding)
(Drew screaming)
We have that in common.
You're not so great on the show.
Ah, I'd say "Chandeliers" every single day,
or "All my life."
(Scarlett laughing)
I mean, I quote your SNL characters on a daily basis.
It's so funny 'cause Colin wrote
a lot of those characters and all those pieces and stuff.
And it's such a funny thing looking back on it now,
but it was just, the timing was good.
When we met timing was right.
So you knew him.
Did you ever find him attractive?
Or was one other time, all of a sudden it looked different?
I mean, he's a very, I think, a very cute guy.
But the other times that I was there,
I was in a relationship.
And I was not like, "Oh, he is cute, but whatever."
And this time, it was the timing was right.
Yeah, I think he looked differently to me
because I was available, it was just,
the timing has to be right.
I think I've definitely been in relationships
where the timing was not right.
And I also kind of think you have to recognize
when it's not, obviously,
if you know if it's not the right person,
it's not the right person.
But sometimes it's a good person, but the timing is off.
And it's important to be open to that too.
You know what I mean?
(upbeat music)